this is such a good idea by the way this
is a phenomenal idea this is a 10 out of
10 opportunity and uh dude he pitched me
why haven't I not invested in this
[Music]
all right what's up we got a banger we
got a doozy we got a we got a two-man
Trio here and uh it's just me and Sam No
guest today uh Sam what's up
nothing I've liked having guests
actually normally I hate it lately I've
enjoyed it what's the difference so we
should do more
I like the people we've chatted with
it's been better yeah not like those
other crusty guests in the past
[Laughter]
um I have got a meaty topic it looks
like I don't know if you have meaty ones
but you have four good ones but they're
smaller is that right all right I'm
gonna tell you about a business that I
think is kind of interesting Ben Ben put
this on my radar um
yesterday he goes he goes dude uh your
sister should open a play Street a play
street I was like what the hell's a play
street so I look it up
have you ever heard of this thing play
Street Museum probably not you're not
you don't have little kids but basically
imagine like
a good for you version of Chuck E cheese
I'll start with that as a as the analogy
so like Chuck E cheese is you know
um it's like having the street is like
um come eat rat pizza at my child Casino
[Laughter]
dude my parents used to say the they're
I always thought the Chuck E Cheese near
my house had burnt down but they just
got to say no it burnt down we can't go
anymore if I drove by there when I got a
license and it wasn't burnt down I just
thought it had burnt out
that was their excuse they said it
burned down 16 years older just slamming
the steering wheel just like God damn it
this video like it's like it's like one
of those facts your parents tell you
when you're five and you just believe it
to be true like totally you know I think
I thought my I told you my my father one
time said real men don't drink with
straws but he was referring to like a
Jack and Coke so like for years I was
like oh we don't we're not allowed to
drink from straws
it's like the Chuck E cheese the Chuck E
cheese on Chippewa burnt down you know
it's not there anymore Chuck E cheese on
what for what that was the Street
Chippewa
uh too good all right so let's have this
thing play street is basically you go
there it's a nice Clean Plate it's like
like a dream playroom for your kids so
it's like they got a giant train set
they have some learning games they got
like you know the floors all it's like
child safe and you basically beautifully
15 bucks beautifully done and you get to
play for an hour and a half or something
like that and so Ben goes yeah I've been
going to this place and I see that
basically the one near me at least he
goes I think they're doing 50 Grand a
month like a 50 Grand a month that's
kind of a lot and he goes yeah he goes
they basically they have and I forgot
the exact numbers but it's like seven
sessions a day it's 15 each
and you have 25 kids I think in the in
the thing at once
um and he goes they're basically 75 full
in these sessions you kind of do the
math you're like all right that gets you
kind of like the 40K plus you can host
your kids birthday parties there in the
nights and weekends and so some people
do that he's like I think they're
probably you know an extra eight to ten
K of of sort of event Revenue uh per
month and then if you look at the cost
you know you got your rent it's probably
like you know 5K and you have to yeah
you have your staff your teach you're
sort of like your your supervisors or
whatever that are like overseeing the
the play space and like resetting it
re-cleaning it in between sessions
um
I think I'm pretty sure this thing is
like netting uh something like 30k a
month
um in profit maybe 25k a month in profit
and and they have tons of these
locations yeah so so it turns out
they're franchising or something like
that I don't know if these numbers are
true by the way this is like complete
guesswork on my side but I wouldn't be
surprised my sister owns uh some
preschools in San Francisco and the
numbers are somewhat similar now that's
different that's you know they pay you
know a lot more but for for you know
regular schooling uh but it's
interesting to me that these play spaces
can uh can do so well and it's like it's
weatherproof it's like you know you do
it like I know with me like we go to
Target three times a week you might ask
yourself John what do you what do you
need from Target so much don't you know
you can order online and what I tell you
is this is uh this is daycare for me
like I like Sean goes to Target so much
that in his home you have this like
Target like a Target checkout playset
and a Target like grocery cart that you
you said you had to like find because it
was like a collector's edition or like
it was all sold out everywhere right
moms go crazy for this thing you had to
like buy it on eBay and do a big markup
yeah exactly these Target mini grocery
carts uh kids love them because they're
they're used to seeing the kids like to
do anything they've seen their parents
doing so the whole mini grocery checkout
plus plus Target cart is uh is I can
hide the band so I go there often and I
do it because you got to kill time it's
like how do I kill 90 minutes and
ideally and I would do something that's
like enriching to them in a worst case
scenario we just go to Starbucks or
Target or whatever and um this would be
better I would gladly pay 15 bucks for
my kids to be able to go play in a place
that's not a Park which is like weather
weather dependent so I think these are
really cool ideas
um I think I think this play Street
thing is a cool idea and I could see
this uh you know this franchise doing
like you know decently well probably not
the best franchise in the world but I
think it could do decently well
where are the locations they're like
Texas uh there's like none in California
none of New York it's like a bunch of
like but what are they it's like a it's
like a blank commercial space
um so like you don't need any food stuff
uh so you just you know it's like just a
blank like retail space huh yeah I mean
their branding is pretty pretty good
it's like kind of like how Escape rooms
work Escape rooms work because right
they require no specific real estate
they can operate in a very small
footprint and they take like two staff
to run at any all day and so Escape
rooms actually are like you know fairly
fairly good you know franchise
businesses or they were for a period of
time now unlike an escape room which is
kind of like you don't know if Escape
rooms are a fad or if they're going to
be like popular three years from now
um these you kind of know are going to
be popular because it's like yeah every
parent's got this problem all right let
me tell you about another another thing
like this another problem you haven't
really thought about there's a business
called 260 sample sale you ever heard of
this no uh let's Google it it's like
kind of a cool New York thing so what
what they do is any e-commerce or
fashion brand has a ton of you know
photo samples or product samples that
they get from their manufacturer
they use them in their photo shoots
um to create the the pictures on the
website or for advertisements or
marketing or whatever and then those
don't live in the warehouse like they
live like where the photographer is or
where their office is and you just end
up piling up boxes and boxes and boxes
of photo samples
um you know over time because let's say
you you know most fashion brands or
apparel brands have yeah thousands of
skus for each SKU you had a sample made
before you had the production one made
but you didn't just have one sample made
you have each of the sizes made and
because you needed it for the photo
shoot
um to be able to show the range or be
able to cast different types of models
and so what ends up happening is you get
a ton of these samples over over the
years that you can't really it's like
not worth your time to get rid of
um and so this business popped up again
like
you know the markets are like you know
water and water's gonna just float
everywhere there's an empty crevice
there's an empty crevice in this market
here for getting rid of these samples so
what they do is 260 samples so it says
send us your [__] brand and we will host
a pop-up where we're going to sell you
along with a bunch of other brands
um all at a great markdown so we have
high quality Brands add a markdown
because these are samples so you're not
like training your customer that like
you know hey this is like TJ Maxx
discount or something like that it's
it's a good story this is these are
samples that you're going to get uh for
for less and they'll like they'll just
give the brand a commission back they'll
say oh you know every time we sell
something of yours you get a small
commission it's better than nothing it
takes it out of your space how'd you
how'd you find this
this is totally out of your out of your
dude they're only based in La Miami New
York and the pictures are like smoking
hot women and then like uh uh it looks
like a a picture of like a huge line out
of a warehouse in SoHo so a lot women
and women of those things I don't do it
you know your boy doesn't do it yeah so
um yeah none of this checks your box
yeah your boy's so married and so in the
house that is I did not go to this
you're right but I'm in the e-commerce
world I got my own e-commerce Brand Plus
I know and talk to a lot of other
Commerce people and I know about this
problem and so I heard about this
solution and I think it's very clever
um I think it is a smart thing to do I
also think these guys are not that well
known and they're only doing it in
certain
um certain areas certain locations and
whatever I think this could be done many
times over I think I think like a
aspiring Hustler could do this by
vertical so you could go get a bunch of
health and wellness and fitness brands
or Beauty Brands and be like hey beauty
brands and that's your products and
we're gonna we'll have a stations where
you could demo them and Sample them and
then buy them
um so I think you could do this for
other verticals I think you could just
do this in other places like hey if
these guys are doing New York and La I
think that their locations like Beverly
Hills of Brooklyn or something
do this in Texas do this in um do this
in different different parts of the
country I think you could have uh you
know it's like your own little farmer's
market it's your own flea market that
you you get to to stock and run
um but you don't have to do it as a
full-time job so you could do it with
every quarter or twice a year or
something like that and still have it be
successful so I thought this was a cool
have you heard
do you know Kingsford Charcoal you
you've seen it it's like the most
popular car called like the blue do you
know how that was created I think it's a
byproduct of something else right what
was it a exact productive wood four oh
four so Ford uh when when when Ford was
making cars they had to like you know
have all these furnaces making metal and
they took like the leftover Char and
they're like what should we do this and
so they pushed it together and compact
it really tight and that's how charcoal
came to be and that's like a byproduct
business and I love byproduct stuff you
know it's kind of like it's tangentially
it's kissing cousins with like the
sharing economy I love that stuff I love
byproduct stuff and this is one of those
that's awesome this is actually quite
cool their website is really challenging
to use which is uh I think actually a
good sign uh because I can't tell like
apparently they do sell stuff online
right but it's mostly but one thing I do
hate whenever I go to New York dude
seeing people wait in line to buy like
Supreme clothing like just press
yourself put the gun in my mouth man
like I'm never doing that I'm not doing
that I'm not gonna wait in line and
spend my valuable time to purchase a
thousand dollar like thing that should
cost only thing worse than that is
bottle service at a club it's like the
guys who are paying you know seven
thousand dollars for a table to and
paying a thousand dollars per bottle
that they could literally walk across
the street buy for forty dollars it's uh
it's like oh you're a chump come to this
line please please please come right
ahead come right ahead you you walk
through the chump line I'm not a man of
God but when Jesus made like the list of
seven deadly sins the example of
debauchery and gluttony was people
waiting in line for five hours to go to
a supreme store I mean like whatever
like I see that stuff I have like this
is the worst form of consumerism I
cannot stand this I so I they have these
pictures here and it turns me off bye
man
I I would maybe buy this online but I
stand in the line I'm not standing in
line with a bunch of these people to buy
this stuff I can't stand that whenever I
see that it makes me want to like throw
away everything and go live here's an
idea you're gonna like more
um host chair so got a DM from a guy
named Michael Fisk and he shows me this
thing called hostshare.com
um and he goes here's the here's here's
here's the situation you have a
short-term rental right yeah a property
um yeah shout it out so people can go
stand at marathonranch.com Marathon
Ranch Marathon Ranch is it.com yeah or
dot Co I don't know yeah.com Marathon
Sam comes by has dinner with you gives
you a massage it's fantastic so
um you don't have 100 occupancy right
you have some nights that are unused is
that correct
a 60 occupancy rate is is a profitable
amount so you got let's say 40 That's
unused nights what you doing with those
nights this is the sharing economy bro
what you doing with those nights Michael
Fisk has an answer for you his answer is
trade your unused nights with other
hosts who have unused nights you stay
for free there they stay for free at
your place and um I think this is a
really smart idea I don't know how many
hosts let's Google this how many
posts on Airbnb I don't know how many
properties they have or how many hosts
to four million okay so you have a
market of four million hosts that you
could make a inter host
um
like Network basically where you say hey
if you're a host you get to travel for
free
um so you get to I know I don't know how
they make things equal so like if your
property is way more dope than somebody
else's I don't know how you make that uh
that trade uh thing okay how do you
normalize the values across properties
we calculate how many shared nights you
would be staying in in exchange for 21
in exchange for the 21 days of travel
per year the formulas established a
higher higher value properties share
last night's lower value property share
more nights so for instance if your
average night is 500 you'll share
approximately 15 nights of the Year
whereas if you're 100 you got to share
45 nights in a year take to the same
minimum that's great so like what's your
property per night right now uh 700 700
so you're gonna basically what they'll
say is hey make your thing open for 12
days out of the year
and then in exchange you get 21 days
free booking in this network would you
take that deal that's yeah in fact I do
so go to live live kindred.com so it's
Kindred
k-i-n-d-r-e-d and then live
um
so I use this service so my dream
situation is I want to find like another
couple that has like similar style or
like once as I do that lives in New York
and they want to be in Austin and we can
just Swap and I've not found a good
solution for that but there's this thing
called lit live Kindred Kindred that I
do that I have used where someone will
stay at my home when I'm not there and
then I get credits for the marketplace
and then like I'm gonna go to Taos New
Mexico like I have like eight credits
because someone stayed at my house for
eight nights and I know that so I'm
gonna go and stay somewhere else for
free and it's actually pretty cool I
wish that it was just like a direct swap
so I could do six months here and we
could just swap six months for six
months but but I've been using services
like these I actually think that I don't
think I'm not bold enough to say like
this is the future but I think that like
you know there are a lot of people like
me who do split time dude finding a
place for those split like when you
split time it's really challenging I'm
always looking for a good solution yeah
that's uh
that's good I didn't know that something
like this exists so with this do you
it's hard and I think they raised money
by the way from Andrea yeah you give up
your space is that right so you give up
you put your space in the network but
you still have to pay or you it's free
uh I there's some type of service fee
frankly I don't think it's a good
business uh I don't understand how they
make money and because what I said what
I signed up for I was like I'm getting a
lot of value I'm not spending a lot of
value I don't know how you guys are
doing this so like that's a BC subsidy
right now you're getting that Andreessen
Horowitz yeah value Exchange
yeah so like we're trying to use our
credits quickly because I think I don't
know if they're gonna stay in business
or not because I don't I don't
understand how it works but it is
awesome if it's awesome if it does work
uh that's hilarious
um so yeah I like these types of
businesses where where uh or that solve
this problem uh is host share popular I
think I just created it
yeah if you could pull it off it's
pretty amazing it's a smart model I
think it's hard to pull off because like
I don't understand how host share makes
money I think they have to charge a flat
membership so I think they have to
basically say it's 500 or a thousand
dollars a year to be in the network and
um
you know you only pay if you use more
than five nights or something like that
make it a make it a fair trade and um
you know I think I think basically then
they're trying to get a subscription
right so they're trying to say can I get
50 000 people to pay us a thousand
dollars a year
um on this subscription there's a few
things like that I forget what the big
one is called but there's they there's
things like for Luxury Rentals where I'm
almost certain that they just partnered
with hotels where you pay like five
grand a year do you know what I'm
talking about it's called avanta yeah I
don't know the name of it but I know
what you're talking about it's like you
get access to the second time for
boutique hotels yeah and I've looked
into them when I originally saw it I
didn't have enough money like I I wasn't
in the spot that I could do it and so
I've been looking for things like this I
actually I really like these businesses
there's one there's this company called
uh the nerd wallet of England I forget
what it was called it's called Uh money
markets oh yeah yeah there's a guy named
Simon who started it and so basically he
started like the nerd wall he started a
Blog that compared like mortgage rates
and things like that and then if you
bought one or got a mortgage through him
you got affiliate fee it's uh I think
it's called super money market is what
it's called it's publicly traded in
England anyway the guy sold all his
shares after he took it public 20 years
later and he now owns this thing called
like Simon's Resorts and so it's this
rich guy who went and bought like 50
Resort or 50 like really nice homes
around the world and I actually don't
know they they frame it up like this is
his personal stuff and you can just use
it when he's not there uh but it's
actually pretty cool and so I love these
types of things because I think they're
just neat to like buy all this [__] and
share it with everyone I think it's
really cool yeah I like that because I
think about a little random experiment
I'm gonna do so I want to make for this
Christmas season
a deep fake Santa
so basically you're going to be able to
come on the site and pay
35 and you
um
and you type in your message you could
say hey wish my daughter Jessica uh
Merry Christmas tell her great job with
the soccer thing and
um be nice to her brother
big sports fan huh
great legs and soccer
and so you'll be able to type in that
message and then it'll basically create
a video that Santa's saying this to you
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
try this thing that replit has so
replied has this new thing where you
could basically Buy
developer Cycles have you seen this
no but so you can go so let's say you
need something built you can basically
just go and buy you can put up a bounty
so you're like all right I want somebody
to build me this deep fake Santa it's
got to do a b and c and you put up a
bounty you put up put up the dollars and
then people will just build it for you
and
um
and you can you basically have an award
so it's kind of like a uh uh like 99.
yeah exactly and and you do it in their
currency which is called cycles and so
they kind of help you estimate like
roughly how many how many cycles should
this be for this to to work out
um but I haven't used it yet I really
want to try this bounty thing I think
it's great because so you're gonna uh
you're gonna pull an Emerson you're
gonna uh you're gonna be this smart guy
who just does a money grab uh no I'm
gonna bring I'm gonna pull uh Justin
Mayers I'm gonna bring the joy of the
Christmas of belief really of the belief
in Magic uh to millions of kids around
the world this Christmas what are you
doing for the children this year Sam
is that your is you're gonna do the
Justin Bears pitch like so we had a
problem we wanted to bring joy to
children like and we thought what better
way to do that than a 50 card a world
full of war and divisiveness
Joy is all we have left it is what they
call the last refuge and people say that
magic is Magic but the magic is getting
people to believe the magic and how do
you get people to believe using deep
fake technology and that's what we
how do you get people to to Believe In
You Lie we're gonna we're gonna create a
fake cartoon about a fake person we're
gonna charge real money and it's gonna
be a fantastic result
are you really gonna do this yeah
because I really want to try this uh
Bounty thing I want to play with this uh
I think this could be what's the URL
going to be
um I think it's going to be called
Santa's real uh you know.org give it a
DOT org
let's make all of our businesses.org
just so we can like just so we can be
prepared to other people yeah
for a long time I wanted to make my
businesses.net so people would think
that I've been around for a long time
yeah but dot org is way better I'm going
to do a DOT org that's way better than
that stupid ass XYZ crypto [__] I
want to dot org is that what they are or
like dot AI dot Io if you have a data IO
like I'm not into it I want a DOT org
we are a for-profit DOT org it's
fantastic is that what dot org means I
think you have to be a non-profit for
taking a DOT org
but who makes that decision is there
like a governing that you have to like
present your EIN for your 501 3C or
something like that I have no idea I've
never done this to be clear I've always
been firmly in the.com Camp but I'm
ready to uh I made my nut and I'm ready
to go and get get my DOT org on for the
rest of my life
that's like uh on stage Andrew or
backstage we were like so what are you
doing and he used the p word I know
philanthropy slandered us with the
philanthropy yeah it's like dude if you
don't say that word around me don't say
philanthropy don't flex with me bro and
uh so now instead of philanthropy it's
dot orgs
a
wilkinson.org go ahead and email me
there
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
today I want to talk about Vice vice.com
the reason I'm talking about them is
because they are about to declare
bankruptcy right
cue the Michael Scott clip where he just
walks out and declares bankruptcy
let's think about that I love that clip
now yeah I I agree most every joke I've
said on this podcast I've stolen from
that show
um so the reason I want to talk about
them is not because of Vice but because
of the story of the founder Shane Smith
and if you're under the age of 26 Vice
probably means nothing to you they've
actually like very quickly lost
relevancy but to give you some
background on what Vice is
so Vice originally was up like a punk
rock magazines based out of Montreal so
it was three Canadian guys one of those
guys being Gavin McKinnis you know who
Gavin McKinnis is no who's that have you
have you heard of proud boys proud boys
like the political thing
yeah he started proud okay
which a lot of people don't realize and
so it was like these three like kind of
like punk rocker guys and Gavin
McKenna's being one of them Shane Smith
who I'm going to talk about today was
the other one and basically the way it
started was they got like a grant from
the government where they were able to
launch this magazine and that's how it
started it started as a skateboarding
punk rock magazine and they would write
like these amazing articles where it was
like vice's guide to drugs and they
would like write all these stories about
drugs they would use the n-word all the
time they would like they were like wow
it's kind of like you know how like some
you probably don't know about this but
like in the punk rock Community they
like sometimes will like talk about
Nazis they talk about like use racist
language but they do as like a shock
Factor because it's like I want to be in
your face that type of thing that that's
what Vice was all about I don't remember
I don't know if you remember like the
old school covers of these magazines but
it would be like a tab of LSD on like a
hot chicks uh tongue do you remember
like I don't remember seeing device
magazine I remember reading something
actually they called it just zines is
there a difference between magazine in a
magazine because that's what that's what
I just just the just the culture if it's
someone's a Zine it's typically more
it's like a punk rock thing whereas if
it's a magazine it could be like GQ okay
gotcha
so you've never seen these but it
started out as like hardcore punk rock
where they would write articles about
um
doing drugs having sex like just rock
and roll [__]
and Matt started getting picked up and
so they started this company in 94 but
in 99 they moved to New York and that
was like where things changed and that's
right where like the internet Just Got
Started what looks like you're looking
at something I'm looking at the magazine
covers and I'm and you're saying rock
and roll and I was just thinking about
like
this is what cool like basically like
this is what influential people uh it's
like kind of like musicians are
influential people and they did the
stuff it's like the the tongue with the
LSD on it it's like someone just biting
a tuft of hair I don't know why there's
a bunch of hair in someone's mouth and I
was just thinking about pod and roll and
how it would be just like someone
entering a cold plunge someone
meditating so it's like yeah we're part
of that pot and roll uh yeah we were the
famous podcasters you know I mean
they're all just on a cold hot cold man
it's crazy the temperature variance is
insane
yeah the definition of cool has changed
which is actually part of the thing I
want to discuss but so the internet
starts coming around in the late 90s
they raise a little bit of money like
two million dollars they move down to um
they moved down to New York and that's
where they like really get going and so
they create the website advice.com
originally was a magazine there was a
free magazine that they would just hand
out and they would make money off ads
and it would be the three of them
writing articles and they would do
something that I used to do all the time
where they would have like fake authors
so it would be like someone who wasn't
real just [__] making up stories is
really what it was which is you know it
was an entertainment magazine so that's
fine
but they start growing and it takes off
after a handful of years and so they've
kind of created this thing at the time
now we just know it as like branded
content where it was now sometimes
people call them advertorials things
like that but basically their whole
shtick was
we're gonna make awesome content and
we're gonna get the eyeballs of
Millennials which back then Millennials
were like the Gen Z today you know it
was like The elusive hard to reach
audience and they said we're gonna reach
these millennials
and we're gonna make the best content
and we're just gonna plaster your logo
on there and that's gonna be good enough
for you and this is like pre-facebook so
like performance advertising wasn't
really much of a thing so it was like
the way to advertise and eventually they
blow up and the important part of this
story isn't exactly that they blew up
because they did but the story is like
the Antics that they went along and and
built this thing with and so
they raised money from Rupert Murdoch
who's you know the founder of fox they
raised money from all these amazing
people Viacom eventually they raised
money at a six billion dollar valuation
today they're nothing but they still
make 600 million dollars a year in
revenue and so I want to talk about some
of the crazy stuff that the founder did
as well as how their business model
works and so have you ever heard of the
the guy Shane Smith who is the CEO and
kind of the main man never all right so
he had a whole bunch of interesting
things that he did so if you Google
Shane Smith you'll probably see like
pictures of him like it's a it's a a guy
who almost looks like a punk rock Santa
Claus where he's kind of like a bigger
guy and he like you'll see like he's got
sleeve tattoos and you'll see him
shirtless all the time and smoking a
cigar do you like see any pictures like
yeah he looks like um he looks a little
bit like the guy who's the number two
guy in billions I forgot what the guy's
name is uh like not not ax but his his
right hand man yeah looks a lot like
that guy if that guy had just like chest
tattoos if he just had like a tattoo
around his nipple that'd be this guy
dude so he's just like crazy and so Vice
originally the way that they became
respected is they would do all this
crazy stuff but it was him doing it
Shane the CEO and so he would go to
Liberia during uh when they're having a
Civil War and he would just bring a
camera and just get dropped in Liberia
and figure it out in 2013 he traveled to
North Korea because he organized a
basketball game between the Harlem
Globetrotters and the national team of
North Korea and that was like the big
stick and then eventually do you
remember hearing about Dennis Rodman
going to uh North Korea that was for a
vice documentary and they would make
these like
free documentaries and they would post
them on it was originally their site and
then they moved to YouTube and they
would get lots of views and they would
like
put like an Intel logo on there and
that's how they made money and so they
and so he was known for walking around
his office of like Vice and I've been to
the office it's like as magnificent as
you would think it's like the coolest of
the cool and he would walk around
shirtless and he would just like
say crazy stuff he was known for just
being like this Wild guy and so one time
when he hired a CEO
her name was Nancy this was recently he
said we're the monitor where the modern
day body and Clyde and we're here to
take all your money and he would just
say stuff like that all the time there
was another time when they were just
getting started and uh I believe it was
into it they came um was it into it or
IBM one of those they came to the office
in order to uh pitch or vice was going
to pitch into it and so what they did
was there was a really shitty office at
the time 24 hours before the meeting he
built like a glass uh conference room so
it looked legit and so you could see
your employees and then he went and
hired a bunch of like actors and got
tons of friends to come and work in the
office to make it look like they're
important because he always like said
something like um
we don't want them to think that we're
or what do you say we want them to think
that we're rich like they like he was
like we're gonna act as it right and he
did and they eventually got a 25 million
dollar deal from this company and it
worked out and there was another time
where there was this uh a 2003 Vice made
it their documentary on themselves and
he tells a story about when they started
the company how he got arrested in
Bangkok uh Bangkok and he said something
like a few years later they were like
yeah remember that story you talked
about being imprisoned in Bangkok and he
was like yeah yeah I remember that and
he goes tell me more about that he goes
well
I made it all up we needed a story on
how that we needed a story on how the
company started and I heard the story
from someone else so I just took it over
and we needed and I just had to take
make it mine he's like I want something
over three and uh decided that was my
life
dude he would do crazy stuff like that
all the time there was another time
where I was reading this interview with
him
he uh there was this headline about how
he spent three hundred thousand dollars
at dinner in Vegas and a Reporter Goes
did you really spend three hundred
thousand dollars for dinner he goes no
it was 380 000 plus tip and it was
barely dinner it was mostly wine uh and
so he's just he the guy's like wild he
even tells uh crazier stories where he
goes this was a quote from uh the uh
Financial Times here we go I would be at
the party and would just go get wasted
take Coke have sex with girls in the
bathroom and then get uh and then
afterwards mail my advertisers drugs
because I knew if I sent them a bunch of
drugs in the mail they would keep buying
ads with us and he admits all this stuff
it's crazy
mancraft I just don't get it well so
check this where did we go wrong was it
when we mailed our customers drugs or
when I did drugs during the day when I
was working with my shirt off having sex
in the bathrooms dude he tells a story
about him and his co-founders having
threesomes with like people who are
going to buy ads with them and he says
that they were like Mobsters who
accidentally clanked shovels together
while they are bearing a body
if that analogy makes sense when someone
was like what's it feel like having a
having sex with your co-founder and you
know do you guys ever like touch he goes
yeah but it's just like two Mafia guys
and our shovels accidentally complaint
while we're preparing the body
[Laughter]
wow this guy is a showman he's a total
Showman
of course it didn't work out well
in all seriousness did uh totally blew
it it didn't it didn't work out well for
the company but it worked out for him so
Google Shane Smith house yeah I see a 50
million dollar house I'm up two steps
ahead he already Googled it
so this there's this amazing article
that came out in 2008 where it's all
about Shane Smith and it says Shane
Smith's living large and it documents
his new house that he purchased for 30
million dollars I think and it's this
beautiful mansion
up in uh La somewhere
while he recently sold it for 50 million
dollars so like this guy has totally
come out on top of this of this whole
thing and I it just really fascinating
that he basically came in he spent about
15 20 years doing his thing right before
like Ty the tide change and like these
guys were the opposite of woke now Vice
is like the woke us of the woke but
right before that change happened he got
his money he got out and he bounced and
he hired a CEO and uh his story is super
super fascinating and so you've never
heard of him I've never heard of him I
briefly knew that Vice started as a as a
Zine or a magazine what's your main
takeaways because this is entertaining
because this guy's like Felix Dennis
just like reincarnated
um so what's your takeaway you're a
media guy
you're you're a bit of a wild man what's
your take on this not that one I mean
this guy makes you look like a like a
you know choir boy or something but uh
what's your takeaways from this story
I have a bunch of takeaways and so but
first let me tell you how their business
model works because that's part of my
takeaways so a lot of people don't
realize how they make money they're
going bankrupt now but they still make
600 million a year in Revenue but it's
just like wildly unprofitable so they
their company it's basically like I
consider it like a mortgage-backed
security for media and so do you
remember like the mortgage-backed
Securities of 2008 where it was
basically like Banks would buy like tens
of thousands of mortgages in one tranche
turns out like 4 000 of the 10 000 were
[__] that's exactly what Vice does and
so they they got famous because
they only had like 20 or 30 million
monthly visits to their website vice.com
which isn't a ton that's not a ton for
hundreds of millions in Revenue what
they did was they did uh they partnered
with
omgfacts.com
distractified.com and all these other
click bait websites and they would roll
that up and so they would sit call them
part of the vice Network and so they
would tell people uh you know like Intel
or whoever the big advertisers are look
we reach all of uh Millennials and we
have a hundred million 200 million
monthly uniques to our Network in
reality it was on like [__] sites like
you know all those other things and that
was like once that came out it was kind
of frowned upon and then the other way
they made money was they had an agency
called virtue like Vice and virtue which
was pretty clever but their whole
company is basically a creative agency
so they would make content for Snapchat
Facebook and then eventually HBO and
they would get paid like a service fee
basically for it and it was basically
one big agency and that's how they made
money
which brings me to the takeaways take
away one
if you're going to be a company that
makes money from multiple different
streams of Revenue you gotta nail one
first they didn't even nail one like
stream of Revenue they had like five
other things that added up to a lot but
not one of them worked wonderfully at
least not enough to be profitable so
that's one major takeaway the second
major takeaway is they would always say
they're going to be the next Disney they
go we're going to be a mini Disney Shane
once said we're worth 10 billion right
now but conservatively I think we're
gonna be worth 40 or 50 billion in a
couple of years that couple of years
would have been like in 2020 or
something never worked out he goes we're
going to be just like Disney except with
Like Cocaine
didn't work out why because no one likes
them if you're gonna build the next
Disney you got to be like people gotta
love you you know people love Mickey
Mouse they don't really love like Shane
Smith you know and all that stuff you
know they like them they don't they
don't really love them so if you're
going to be a media company like that
you have to have
something that people love the next
thing is news if you're going to be in
the news business that's really really
hard because you have to stay relevant
and I actually think that you should be
something that typically people don't
grow out of but they grow into meaning a
Wall Street Journal a New York Times if
you're going to be like one of these
Publications economists Financial Times
things like that you want to grow into
it meaning like as you get older you
want to like aspire to be able to read
it and like it and understand it and
brag about it whereas advice it was like
I'm no longer 28 years old reading about
this stuff is not exactly cool and plus
the people working there you kind of
look silly I've always thought about
this about barcel sports I'm like dude
Dave Portnoy is getting older like some
of these Antics are kind of not going to
be cool anymore they're more so like
pathetic you know what I mean and that's
kind of happened with advice yeah you
basically uh you either stay with the
stick
and you just start to look like a clown
as you get older and older or you gotta
sell get out and change your life you
know change your lifestyle and uh it's
pretty interesting because it's very
hard to let go because hey if you
weren't such a nut you wouldn't have got
that got this level of success in the
first place so it's kind of like a
self-fulfilling prophecy and then on the
second second uh part of it you know
it's very easy to get addicted to the
character the the fame the money that
comes with with acting a certain way
you're being rewarded rewarded rewarded
and then now you're 57.
and you're you know oh you know you're
Vince McMahon now or your Hugh Hefner
now or you're whoever right like it's
hard to believe the character uh even
though you might actually maybe you
actually should uh you know grow out of
it
um anyways but I'm glad that these guys
don't grow out of it it's for our
entertainment thank you thank you for
your service Shane Smith it is and the
last two things
if you're gonna build a media company
avoid New York City like when you're a
creative Services business you need it's
a it's a talent Arbitrage and it's
really hard to do that when you're in a
really high cost of living City like New
York and also
you saw that they like became this whoa
company which I don't entirely believe
like go woke go broke like that type of
thing I do think that um
I think that like there's a niche you
can make money in any Niche it doesn't
matter if you're woke or not
but they like changed that way when that
wasn't originally what they did and I
think they changed that way because they
moved to like Williamsburg and
everything like that and it totally
changed their uh their their stick but
the last thing is actually a compliment
so you texted me the other day right
before you're about to go on to you're
gonna speak at this conference and you
said uh
what did you say about to drop some
Showmanship on these [__] is that
what you said about to show these
[__] some Showmanship yeah and that
is totally true and that is what he did
and frankly even though he it seems as
though he conned a lot of people he kind
of got the last laugh and he had
Showmanship throughout the entire thing
and had it worked out it would have been
a lot cooler but having Showmanship it
totally worked by the way there's like
story like oh do you get nervous before
public speaking it's like I don't know
man
if I was nervous probably wouldn't be
thinking I'm about to drop some
Showmanship on these [__] it's a
different attitude exactly versus I hope
I don't mess up
dude he like throughout his career if
you can like there's so many crazy
stories about this guy it's all about
Showmanship he does the wildest stuff
where he like tells Stories the way he
tells stories it captures your attention
and some of his employees were like when
I'm with Shane I feel like I'm going to
war and I'll go to any war with him
right or there's like uh Johnny
Knoxville did a interview and he was
talking about Shane and he goes he's the
greatest uh leader you could ever have
also the greatest drinking buddy yeah
he like has all of these like amazing
one-liners even if they are full of [__]
but whenever I hear him talk I'm like oh
my God I believe everything you said so
for example have you ever heard me say
the best way to circumvent someone's
[__] detector is to not [__]
I've used that line a couple times I
stole it from him so he would like he
has all these like amazing one-liners
and that Showmanship it's absolutely
captivating there's like a story about
him with Rupert Murdoch and Rupert
Murdoch and Shane are walking and Rupert
Murdoch is like a
you know if you see the movie TV show
succession he's like that guy he's like
a mean old man
and Shane sits down with them and goes
you don't have Millennials but I do I
have everything you don't have and like
he's talking to this billionaire
testosterone
youth
all right but he just like totally like
swings above his weight and I think it's
really fascinating to learn from this
guy so if you're listening to this
Google Shane Smith it's there's like
crazy stories about this guy good
segment by you good good job by you good
job I like that one uh I actually have a
spin-off of that you mentioned a company
in there that I was like hmm that sounds
familiar I kind of remember this name so
you said OMG facts do you know who
started OMG facts
I do I forget his name but he's an
oddball right this guy Emerson Sparks
and I met ever since Sparks maybe 10
years ago and when he was building OMG
facts and building uh a network called
dose media he's like a genius right he
is I met him and I was like wow this guy
is super smart
um I actually think that he is kind of
like if he had just applied himself to
some other areas he would have like
totally uh done done some like you know
absolutely amazing things everybody
would know his name versus just kind of
me and half of you knowing his name so
I'm going to tell you a couple things
about Emerson Sports so the guy when he
was 12 years old built a website called
muggle net and I don't know if you're a
Harry Potter guy but I'm I'm a Harry
Potter guy and I was on muggle net all
the time and I used to love this because
it was the number one Harry Potter fan
site in the world tons and tons of
traffic I mean at the time Harry Potter
was like you know Justin Bieber Harry
Potter was was super super famous and in
between the books people wanted a place
to discuss to post theories to post fan
fiction to uh debate you know what
should have happened blah blah
and so muggling that when he's 12 he
builds the super popular site getting
millions and millions of visitors when
he's 18 He publishes a best-selling book
his best-selling book is called uh I
think it's called
Harry Potter should have died
controversial views from the number one
fan site and basically it's like Harry
survived but should he have uh you know
I run the world's biggest fan site for
Harry Potter and here's some of the
controversial viewpoints that people
have about Harry Potter
you could already see this guy's got the
he's got the certain that owes you that
comes with the sandwich
he's got the sauce and uh he's got the
Showmanship and so he I I met him maybe
he was I don't know how old he was maybe
22 or something like this at this point
and um where'd you meet him I don't even
remember man I remember being on a call
with a video call and it was him and I
think his girlfriend at the time and
they were creating something called dose
media and I go so what is it he goes
well we're gonna make like really viral
content so uh they had OMG facts that
was one of their companies they had like
four or five websites like that one that
was like science facts ones that was
funny things one that was whatever
controversial or pop culture stuff like
references to TV shows and things that
were hot right now and they had these
websites and I go okay so how do you
like at the time in my mind I was like
going viral is getting you know
lightning strikes you you know you it's
just not something you try to do it's
just something that happens or it
doesn't happen and it usually doesn't
happen
he's like no no and he had built a
four-part system and this is the first
guy he's like yeah we're a different
type of technology company we have uh 18
engineers and we have four writers and
we reach millions and millions of people
a month and I was like no no it was
actually good I was like so what it what
do the engineers do he's like well
basically all the viral content on the
in the world starts either in one of
three places Reddit
imager or 4chant and he's like basically
I built a detector that would find stuff
that's going that's getting hot on those
on those three platforms first before it
hits Instagram before it hits Facebook
before it hits Twitter uh it's gonna get
popular there first and he goes so we
built a detector then we built a um
like a then the writer basically would
would uh build like like write a summary
and then we built a a b tester that
would basically create headlines
um headlines and uh and and like
different like uh frames of that same
story and it would test them really
quickly that we had a tester that would
spray that out we would pay to get that
in front of like you know five thousand
ten thousand people we'd find what
what's the winning angle and then we
would have the post and then
distribution right and then we would
actually distribute that to our audience
and so we could engineer a higher degree
of virality in every piece of content
why because we're finding the best stuff
we're packaging it quickly with our
writer then we're remixing it with our
automated a b tester that's going to
juice up the headlines and then the
images then we're spraying it out
getting data feedback telling us which
of these 15 variations is the winner and
then we post the winner and um I was
like dude this is amazing and over the
few years I saw him build this up and he
his traffic kept going up and up now the
problem was
traffic wasn't that valuable it was kind
of flyby traffic uh it was kind of like
the lowest common denominator of the
internet and from Facebook I think it
was very dependent on social networks
and then Facebook changed and for a
while Facebook was like rewarding the
hell out of anybody that could post
viral content and then it got two
clickbaity on Facebook and then Facebook
just manually went and unplugged the
like viral engines for for these
companies and so like 10 companies died
like you know uh in that transition I
don't think his totally died but I think
it definitely slowed down and I think he
also grew up and was sort of like what
else do I want to do in my life so now I
just went to by the way really quick
before that before you go on to him did
I have I told you about my partner at
Hampton Joe he had a company called
little things which was the same thing
as that it was a Content like clickbait
website he started it in New York and
then like he had all these he had
multiple floors in an office building
and it was killing it they were at 100
million in Revenue he had a deal sell
they went through due diligence the deal
was going to close in two weeks
that change that you just referred to it
happened to little things at the time
little things was the most trafficked
website from Facebook in the world so it
was like little things and then it was
like huffpo and then like BuzzFeed
BuzzFeed yeah the deal was about to
close I think for a hundred and
something million he was gonna walk away
with 50 million after taxes two weeks
before the money was supposed to go
through that changed happened the deal
he lost the deal and weeks or months
like only a couple months later they had
to shut down the company and it was all
because they built everything on top of
Facebook that's a Mike Tyson gut punch
right like uh and a bird's fly fish swim
and Deals fall through that is the the
the the the sad part about deals that
that is too common
yes and that's very common that's what
happened to this guy Emmett smart Emmett
smart so what happened to him Emerson
Sports
Emerson sorry yes but uh here's his bio
now
um
he's his thing says like AI history
complex systems of Bitcoin then he goes
goal I'm gonna die number one on the
leaderboard of people who changed the
world and so his what he's doing now is
something called non-linear and
non-linear it looks like is basically a
is basically a a company that is funding
people working on AI to make it make
sure that it's safe and so
um so they they fund basically
non-linear entrepreneurs people who are
trying to work on these like exponential
Technologies and so yeah they we
incubate x x risk non-profits I don't
even know what extras nonprofits means
uh by connecting founders with ideas
funding and mentorship and so that's
what he's working on now but this guy's
always going to do interesting things
this guy can't this guy can't be
uninteresting dude when I read about him
I I was like why are you doing this dude
like you're doing this dose media thing
like you seem like a genius you're just
absolutely wasting it this is a what do
you say it's a uh High uh High effort
low or what do you say like the hormuzy
had a good one for this it's a 10 out of
um
10 out of 10 entrepreneur we're going at
a 4 out of 10 opportunity and uh that's
how I felt when I met him I remember
literally like this is now 10 plus years
later I have not spoke to this guy
you mentioned OMG facts and in my mind
I'm like that guy's smart follow up with
that guy right because he left such an
impression on me where I was like this
guy is really really clever really smart
really also like wholesome like even at
the time he was like
uh even though he was working on
something that's like typically I would
say almost everybody I know that's in
this kind of like viral media actually
just like lame there's kind of [__]
and um and I made that like in an
endearing way like you know some people
are [__] and it's all right you're
just like yeah I'm trying to I found
this Arbitrage I'm making it happen
um and so he was not that he was really
soft smoking really really nice guy Ben
says extra risk is the risk that
something could end the world it's an
existential risk okay yeah good so he's
he's Gonna Save the Planet which is dude
and his website is a is a DOT org yeah
Noble mission.org type of guy when I was
in Austin
um a friend of mine was hanging out with
Justin Mayers who's been on the Pod
before I think I can quote this because
I think it's a good quote but he said uh
he goes Justin said the best thing he
goes
it doesn't matter how you make your
first nut just gotta make your first nut
but after you do that then you want to
work on a noble Mission and he's like
dude he's like I like that he's like you
know do whatever you got to do to make
to make your first nut which is you know
get your that first few million dollars
where you're financially free and you're
and you're uh you don't have to have a
job you can work on whatever the hell
you want but then after that don't go
chase the second nut go go after
something that's a noble mission go
after something that's awesome and um
you know very few people actually do
that in fact I don't even think Justin
is doing that at the moment but but I I
love the quote isn't he doing like an
FSA spending store that's like the most
like opportunistic thing I could think
of
the way that he pitched it it was pretty
awesome he said something like uh
obesity in America is like an epidemic
and 60 of people are overweight we want
to make you eat healthier by making it
easier to acquire like you know this
types of food and this type of
healthcare and we're doing it via and
then he like that's where the pitch
comes in all right that's always a good
look so his site I think it's called
true medicine true Med so true Med
he says food is medicine exercise
medicine sleep is medicine we don't mean
this in a theoretical sense food
exercise and sleep are all
scientifically proven to prevent or
alleviate uh physical and mental illness
in short these are all medicine
it's a true Med is a payment integration
that enables qualified customers to use
pre-tax HSA and FSA funds to purchase
health promoting products and services
from their favorite Merchants soon it'll
be available the checkout flow for all
Merchants who are for merchants who sell
healthy food supplements extra equipment
and other health and wellness products
this is such a good idea by the way this
is a phenomenal idea this is a 10 out of
10 opportunity and uh dude he pitched me
why have I not invested in this I mean I
didn't invest because I was just like
saying no to everything and I deeply
regret it I deeply regret it because by
the way this is the best way to pitch a
business which is like you like paint
this like dreary picture like the world
is obese you know did you know that like
if you add up all the terrorist attacks
all the guns all the car accidents it
would only be one-tenth of the people
who die uh you know from being obese
like you know that type of fact and you
say like if we continue this this is
what the outcome is going to be this and
that and and so we need to solve this
the way that we are happy to happen to
be trying to solve this is by doing X Y
and Z and I'm like all right that's a
great pick yeah this is uh wow I am so
jealous that I'm not invested in this
I'm I'm messaging him right now all
right um yeah that's it that's the Pod
we're out of here
[Music]
foreign